[Musique]
le phoque du groenland et la créature la
plus mignonne de l'arctique
certains disent qu'on peut percevoir
dans leur grille le mot maman
cette photo a été prise à une distance
de 2 m il se laisse approcher vous voyez
les phoques sont tous différents
certains ont peur et s'enfuit ils ne
vous laissent pas vous approcher à moins
de 15 mètres
d'autres se laissent prendre dans vos
bras
[Musique]
en raison de la chasse et du
réchauffement climatique leur population
a considérablement diminué au cours des
dernières années le sort des phoques du
groenland préoccupe les scientifiques
auparavant on faisait des recherches
scientifiques on avait des gens pour
observer ce qui se passait là bas à
partir d'avions d'hélicoptères de drones
ou à l'aide d'autres moyens mais le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas eu de recherches de
l'année dernière malheureusement
personne ne sait vraiment ce qui s'est
passé avec les phoques du groenland
nous irons probablement dans cette
région bon non une fois arrivé à
arkhangelsk nous devrons prendre l'avion
pour le village de la banlieue de moscou
fin février il est temps de se préparer
il ne faut pas oublier les jumelles
l'outil le plus précieux pour ce couple
la biologiste anna filipova et le
secouriste du ministère de situations
d'urgences sergueï kovalev pour voir des
bébés phoques en mer blanche
les jumelles sont un outil indispensable
en mer si on a besoin de rechercher quoi
que ce soit il est difficile de s'en
passer
[Musique]
saint petersbourg la capitale du nord de
la russie artiom tara bookeen qui tient
un blog voyage bien de déterminer
l'itinéraire d'une randonnée sur les
glaces de la mer blanche donnée gars à
severodvinsk 470km l'hiver le froid les
animaux sauvages et la solitude ne lui
font pas peur
pour les citadins c'est sans doute un
peu bizarre quand un homme s'apprête à
aller dieu sait où est dieu sait
pourquoi
[Musique]
si tout se passe comme prévu début mars
anna sergei hommes se rencontreront dans
un endroit appelé les tenailles asolo
tizza c'est un hôtel écologique au bord
de la mer blanche scientifique voyageurs
et touristes s'y rendent pour tenter de
savoir s'il reste des phoques du
groenland en mer blanche
et si oui combien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
07/08 celle neuf élèves naias de l'outil
travolta
bonjour voici les conditions
météorologiques actuelles la direction
du vent et de 30 degrés la visibilité
supérieure à 10 nuages froid de manque
et 6 oct à 300 mètres neige mouillée
occasionnels la pression atmosphérique
est de 762 7 6 2 vous ne pouvez vous
rendre à la tenaille asolo tizza qu'à
l'aide de l'un de ces petits avions que
les locaux appellent coucou rooney qui
il n'y a qu'un seul contrôleur aérien
pour le faire atterrir piste dégagée
signaux nettoyer cap d'atterrissage à
192 degrés tout va bien
charge plein au caire j'ai passé la
moitié de ma vie avec toi je n'ai jamais
rompu ce fils qui me relis à l'enfance
on hamm est dévouée à la patrie nous
sommes tous deux les enfants de la n2
un pilote qui ne volent pas avec un
travail qui n'existe pas un écrivain et
journaliste dans un village où il n'y a
même pas de journaux pourtant il y ait
au nikov est membre à la fois de l'union
des écrivains de russie et de l'union
des journalistes russes
sa poésie décrit la vie des habitants de
la côte de la mer blanche mieux que
n'importe quelle encyclopédie
il est créé également sur les phoques et
la chasse aux phoques c'est un très bon
revenu d'appoint pour les habitants la
branche nordique de l'institut pour la
recherche polaire la pêche maritime et
l'océanographie a estimé que sora
milford du groenland pourrait être tués
chaque année sans nuire à la population
de phoques
parce que les animaux se reproduise une
petite tête blanche avec de grands yeux
noirs humide
non pas qu'ils soient tristes ils
doivent simplement être constamment
hydratée
quand un bébé phoque tête il claque des
lèvres comme les humains et leur
fourrure lors donne l'apparence d'une
peluche
les phoques du groenland en l'air si
mignons et c'est vulnérables si on
imagine quelque chose de blanc comme
neige est doux comme on dit c'est
exactement ça quelque chose de doux et
blanc avec de beaux yeux noirs début
mars à nice sergei ont pris ce petit
avion avec un groupe de touristes pour
se rendre à l'etna liasse de l'otite ça
ils se préparent maintenant pour un vol
vers les glaces de la mer blanche à la
recherche des phoques
il examine des cartes de glace discutent
de la météo des vitesses de dérive des
glaces et de l'itinéraire du lendemain
le vent a changé
regarde là tu vois et il ya une pologne
ouverte ici et une polynie ouverte là
toute cette zone est dans les eaux
libres en ce moment c'est de la
recherche
c'est là que la magie se produit vous
devez prendre en compte tant de facteurs
possibles
la météo change tout change la glace
dérivent très vite
l'écotourisme a commencé à se développer
à l'etna ya de l'eau tizza cet afflux de
touristes pourrait attirer l'attention
sur le problème de l'extinction des
phoques du groenland lna et olga ont
parcouru la moitié de la planète
elles sont difficiles à impressionner
mais toutes deux estime que c'est ici
dans le parc national de neige cueilli
peau mourier qu'elles verront un
véritable miracle aujourd'hui
nous espérons assister au miracle d'une
nouvelle vie à la naissance de petits
phoques les bébés phoques blanc tout
mignon et du foot sur la banquise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on ne peut rejoindre les phoques qu'en
hélicoptère il est difficile de prédire
où on les trouvera nous comptons sur
notre intuition et notre expérience
les écotouristes ont eu de la chance
après 1h30 de vol
ils ont finalement pu voir trois bébés
phoques et leur mère sur la banquise
il est très difficile de réaliser quand
on se trouve sur une surface solide que
ce n'est pas la terre ferme que vous
vous tenez en réalité sur une banquise à
la dérive qui a un esprit qui lui est
propre et que la glace pourrait s'ouvrir
sur vos pieds à tout moment et nous
travaillons au milieu de la mer blanche
aussi loin que possible des côtes afin
de ne pas déranger effrayer les phoques
l'hélicoptère a atterri environ 200 m
les touristes doivent continuer à pied
leurs appareils photos et téléphones
prêt à l'emploi
nous avons eu de la chance cette fois
que nous avons vu trois maires floch
être à petit les phoques ne sont pas
très contents qu'on leur prête une telle
attention et regardent leurs visiteurs
avec suspicion
non mais dites moi comment on peut même
penser à chasser ces créatures regardez
les
[Musique]
la seule chose qu'il y aura aujourd'hui
se déroule avec des caméras il faut être
prudent et ne pas trop s'approcher des
phoques
sinon la mer pourrait attaquer ce sont
des animaux curieux est vraiment
sympathique
alors même qu'ils ont été chassés par
l'entente d'année on pourrait penser
qu'ils ont peur des gens mais si vous
vous baisser doucement ça en mouvement
brusque leur maman vous permet vraiment
de vous rapprocher de ses petits c'est
incroyable
les scientifiques parlent de ces sites
de reproduction en usant du terme de
créer schaaphok
je ne sommes pas seulement sur leur
territoire nous sommes carrément à leur
maternité
le bébé phoque nous regardons a déjà
grandir un peu
on dirait qu'il a deux ou trois jours
mais le cordon ombilical est encore
frais et transparent il n'a pas encore
séché
seulement 3 phoque pour ce vol ce n'est
pas ce qu'anna et sergei espérer voir en
théorie devrait en avoir beaucoup plus
ce n'est pas que chaque maire doit avoir
un petit mais il doit tout de même avoir
une bonne quantité
ce n'est pas ça que nous voyons cette
année je suppose que c'est parce qu'il
n'y a pas eu beaucoup de glaces en mer
blanche l'année dernière donc les
phoques n'ont pas pu se reproduire comme
d'habitude
l'interaction avec les phoques du
groenland dure moins d'une heure le
froid empêche d'y rester plus longtemps
les moteurs de l'hélicoptère pour être
au refroidir et ne pas pouvoir
redémarrer
il est temps de partir mais soudain un
nouveau personnage apparaît un morceau
de l'atlantique
c'est un jour de chance pour les
photographes mais pas pour les phoques
qui sont un vrai régal pour les morses
[Musique]
dean pour mu mais l'émotion aujourd'hui
quand vous êtes littéralement à 20
mètres d'un mort ce qui sort de l'eau et
que la mer phoques et son petit commencé
à s'enfuir
c'est la vraie vie ce n'est pas une
photo c'était tellement chouette
formidable bien sûr la mer phoques était
si attentionnés et tendre une vraie
beauté
on a adoré on a vu ce pour quoi on est
venu on aimerait voir un peu plus de
fuck
mais ce n'est pas grave ils auront reçu
que blanchon et ses six millions j'ai pu
l'observer il était à portée de main
la mère s'est un peu calmée et le petit
a rampé plus près de nous un parcours
sportif
[Musique]
pendant que les touristes de l'etna
gazole otis assure veulent les banquises
de la mer blanche
artiom tara bookeen le blogueur de saint
pétersbourg avance avec son traîneau et
partage ses aventures avec ses abonnés
sur les réseaux sociaux aussi mystique
que cela puisse paraître les phoques
l'êtes vraiment sur son chemin
les quatre premiers jours de marche il y
a eu pas mal de tempêtes de neige de
blizzard presque tout autour de moi est
complètement blanc tout se couvre d'une
nappe de brouillard blanc et soudain un
petit point noir est apparu devant moi
c'était un phoque
il était comme un repère comme les
aiguilles d'une boussole c'est arrivé
cinq fois je crois je ne pouvais rien
voir et des phoques apparaissait pour me
montrer où je devais aller si je
comprends bien enfin je suppose ils
n'ont probablement pas une très bonne
vue il voit quelque chose de familier
dans n'importe quel objet en mouvement
ce sont des créatures très très mignonne
et les blanchons particulièrement
la chasse aux phoques du groenland s'est
développée en urss au milieu du 20ème
siècle la fourrure étaient utilisés pour
fabriquer des chapeaux et la viande
hachée servait comme nourriture dans les
fermes d'élevage de visons
[Musique]
dire que la chasse au phoque est une
activité traditionnelle n'est pas tout à
fait honnête c'est une opinion biaisé il
existe une chasse aux phoques
traditionnelle vous prenez un petit
bateau probablement recouverts de peaux
de phoque aussi il s'agit par exemple
d'un groupe de dix hommes sur quelques
bateaux ils allaient un mer blanche
assez des phoques mais elle ne
s'agissait pas de milliers de phoques
les phoques du groenland était apprécié
pour leur fourrure elle reste blanche
pendant environ trois semaines après la
naissance puis elle devient grise
la chasse aux phoques étaient financés
par le gouvernement malgré les pertes
économiques
la chasse aux phoques a continué les
dirigeants russes pensaient que cela
pouvait fournir des emplois à la
population locale ce travail payait bien
des locaux se souviennent encore de
séjour de fin février quand il se
rassembler en groupes et à les chasser
les phoques
c'était terrible les gens avec des gars
fait des massues allait tuer les phoques
des scènes assez troublante il faut dire
les corps étaient placés dans des filets
envoyé à terre que je veux dire il y
avait du sang partout sur la glace et
tout sa rue vous voyez cette petite
créature qui essaient de communiquer un
son qui ressemble à maman et vous devez
là dessus
evgeny agafonov à chasser le phoque
pendant huit ans jusqu'à ce que
l'activité ne cessent le travail était
dangereux
il est toujours possible de tomber à
travers la glace ou de recevoir un coup
d'un phoque
c'est une mer phoques est sur le point
de vous attaquer feriez mieux de courir
elle va vous mettre au charpy moi j'en
ai vu une attaque et notre chef d'equipe
elle a déchiré sa veste
je vis ça de mes propres yeux elle mord
et match tout ce qu'elle attrape
vous pouvez la tenir à l'écart seulement
avec une pique
les chiffres de la chasse était alors
exorbitants et obtenait trois cent mille
blanchon parents à l'époque il pensait
que la population de phoques du
groenland était sans limites et qu'il y
en avait trop ce qui a vraiment
déstabiliser la population de phoques
l'union soviétique s'est dissoute c'est
la chasse aux phoques a pris fin avec
elle il s'est avéré que le jeu n'en
valait pas la chandelle et en 2008 il a
été déclaré que l'abattage des phoques
était un acte de sauvagerie en 2009
le document qui régit la pêche en mer
blanche a été modifié la chasse aux
phoques a pris fin
[Musique]
en 2015 tout à recommencer les règles de
pêche en mer blanche ont été rétablies
elles restent les mêmes aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qu'actuellement la chasse
aux phoques du groenland est autorisée
tant à ce que j'ai commencé à embêter
tout ce que je connaissais pour qu'on
revienne à la pratique du contrôle de
nombre de phoques
je pense qu'il est très important de
comprendre ce qui se passe en réalité
pourquoi ont-ils autoriser la chasse aux
phoques pourquoi il n'ya pas de données
vous voyez pour moi quelque chose ne
colle pas ça devrait pas être comme ça
au début des années 2000 la population
de blanchons en mer blanche a été estimé
à 330 milles au mieux il s'agit des
blanchons là en 2008 il n'y en avait
plus que 128 milles c'est presque trois
fois moins
le changement climatique est devenu une
chose évidente parfois et à de la glace
parfois non nous savons que les phoques
du groenland viennent toujours en mer
blanche au début du mois de mars
toujours fin février début mars au cours
de cette période deux semaines seulement
et s'ils ne viennent pas on ne sait pas
ce qu'ils deviennent
combien de phoques du groenland y at-il
en mer blanche en réalité pour connaître
les chiffres réels des observations
instrumental dans toute la zone de la
mer blanche sont nécessaires avec des
scanners thermiques et des caméras la
russie a réalisé des évaluations de ce
type jusqu'en 2013 la limite cher nook
est l'un des scientifiques qui a
participé dans les années 1990 nous
avons été les premiers à obtenir une
série d'image multi spectrale des
phoques du groenland en mer blanche
c'est une méthode qu'on utilise depuis
1998 les appareils électroniques
enregistre huit fois plus de blanche on
est cinq fois plus de phoques adultes
que l'on peut en voir à l'oeil nu
on n'a désormais plus besoin d'avions
les drones font un excellent travail et
sont beaucoup moins chers et plus simple
à utiliser
nous avons réalisé à un relevé
expérimental des lieux avec de nouveaux
drones au milieu de la mer blanche en
2018 et on a eu l'impression que la
population de blanchons était déjà
inférieur à 100 milles le réchauffement
climatique et la diminution de sources
de nourriture voilà ce qui explique la
disparition de phoques du groenland le
phoque de la dga a été classé menacé sur
la liste rouge de l'union internationale
de la conservation de la nature il ya
déjà longtemps
on ne sait pas non plus combien il en
reste les dernières observations de
phoques della dogana ont été faites en
2012 ou 2013
le nord du lac ladoga quelque part entre
les îles samad sary époux de sarry la
seule manière de venir ici c'est en
aéroglisseur
où êtes vous on a passé les rochers et
où êtes vous allé après côté gauche
etes-vous loin au cas entendue d'accord
on va dans votre direction
nous sommes entrés dans la baie aller
sans la whey
le chercheur dmitrik blaze of un groupe
de biologistes et un berger belge appelé
genia fouilles dans la neige
risquant chaque seconde de se retrouver
dans l'eau ils recherchent des
excréments et des poils de phoque une
femelle phoque della dogana amis passent
et plus il y a quelques semaines
oui absolument c'est sur ge
c'est arrivé ici dans cette cavité de
glace c'est curieux vous voyez il y a
beaucoup de poids là dedans voilà juste
cela nous retirons ses poils de la glace
comme parfois c'est juste un petit
flocon une touffe
voilà deux petits poils ici et par là de
chez sony on ne peut pas recenser la
population en se basant là dessus mais
on peut dire si cette année est bonne
par rapport à une autre du point de vue
de la reproduction des animaux
il y a aussi le taux de survie des
progénitures parce qu'il peut y avoir
plein de petits mais si les conditions
météorologiques sont mauvaises
ils ne survivront pas tous dans ce cas
ce sera une mauvaise année il en va de
même avec les phoques du groenland
quand il ya peu de glace les blanchons
meurent en grand nombre
ou alors ils ne sortent pas dans la mer
de barents pour se nourrir et compte
tenu de l'âge des animaux l'année peut
être considéré comme un échec
démographique les phoques du groenland
et de l'ado gars sont des animaux pago
fils il aime la glace il si un couple
s'y reproduisent y allaient de leurs
petits ému or il n'y a pas eu beaucoup
de glace ces derniers temps ni au lac
ladoga ni en mer blanche
il n'y a pas eu d'évaluation de la
quantité de phoques de ces dernières
années la tendance que vladimir czernik
avait repéré depuis la fin des années 90
et le début des années 2000 ne peut être
ni confirmé ni infirmé
y at il une croissance ou un déclin de
la population qu'est ce qui va se passer
ensuite ça tous les phoques et les
blanches ont encore un autre ennemi en
mer blanche
les pétroliers qui passent à travers les
zones où ces animaux se rassembler
en 2008 à partir des images aériennes
nous avons estimé la densité des
colonisés et puis nous avons analysé à
quel point ces sites avaient été
endommagées par les pétroliers fille
voilà les chiffres étaient extrêmement
élevé de l'histoire
les marins explique qu'un pétrolier
n'est pas un bateau il ne peut pas
contourner les sites où se rassemblent
les phoques mais les défenseurs des
animaux 10 q 6 et rappelle qu'une bonne
réputation est plus précieuse que
l'argent si les consommateurs savait que
l'entreprise ne se soucie pas des
animaux et peut aisément les abattre les
gens c'est serait d'acheter leurs
produits
il refuserait tout simplement les
banques pourraient même refusé de
financer ces entreprises il était
campagne et artyom notre blogueur a déjà
parcouru la majeure partie du chemin
[Musique]
ils s'arrêtent parfois dans des villages
et demande un abri aux habitants les
locaux semblent surpris mais personne ne
lui a jamais dit non peut-être qu'ils me
considèrent en partie comme un fou mais
tout de même comme l'un des leurs en
fait j'aimerais apprendre plein de
choses à leurs côtés parce que les
habitants de la côte
les peaux mort vivent ici depuis plus de
six siècles relâchés soit clair
malheureusement tout cela dépérit sous
nos yeux
je ne veux pas dire que cela meurs je
n'aime pas ce mot mais cela dépérit
[Musique]
les power estime que la chasse aux
phoques donnerait une nouvelle vie au
village et sont convaincus que depuis
l'entrée en vigueur des restrictions
le nombre de phoques dans les mers a
augmenté et qu'ils ont mangé tous les
poissons en raison des restrictions la
population de phoques se reconstituent
et les poissons en souffre et ainsi que
les habitants locaux
un phoque a besoin de 20 kg de poissons
par jour pour se nourrir
t'es combien il y en a dans la
mer actuellement
[Musique]
habile au coach s'amuse vous avez vu des
blanchons ils sont comme des enfants
avec leurs grands yeux larmoyants
c'est très dur psychologiquement
[Musique]
mais quel autre emploi peut-on trouver
ici la chasse est leur gagne pain
et depuis qu'ils ont cessé de les
chasser il n'ya plus de poisson
regardez combien il l'a de phoques ici
ici il y en a plein de syogoc
[Musique]
ils abîment les filets et dévore les
poissons l'année dernière a été un
désastre pour les pêcheurs locaux
il y a trop de phoques maintenant le
chef d'équipé guinea agafonov est aussi
en faveur de la reprise de la chasse aux
phoques
il affirme qu'il y aura enfin du travail
et les gens reviendront dans le nord on
devrait être autorisé à chasser des
blanchons c'est tout vous apprécie pour
l'instant cet interdit natale il y en a
beaucoup maintenant au moins ça fera un
revenu pour les pêcheurs les
scientifiques s'oppose fermement à la
chasse aux phoques
selon lui la chasse commerciale détruira
la population de phoques déjà menacé la
bonne nouvelle est que personne ne
semble intéressé à investir dans cette
affaire pas parce que les blanchons leur
font de la peine mais parce que c'est
coûteux toute la chaîne est perturbé il
n'y a nulle part où vend les produits et
nulle part où les obtenir et puis la
demande en fourrure naturelle est faible
où ils sont économiquement la chasse au
phoque n'avait aucun sens oui tout le
monde comprend que les gens ont besoin
de manger ils ont des maisons des
villages et cetera ils doivent subvenir
à leurs besoins
et tout le monde crie sur les toits que
les villages se vident partout et l'un
va de même pour les villages de la côte
de la mer blanche toutes les personnes
actives part pour la ville
donc ce qui a été proposé et de
développer l'écotourisme
parce qu'il ira certainement un
clientèle qui viendra voir les blanchons
et puis vous n'épuise pas les ressources
comme ça les gens pourraient gagner de
l'argent sans aucun dommage pour la
population de phoques du groenland
vous soutenez les phoques et en même
temps vos affaires vont bien
le blogueur de saint pétersbourg artiom
tara bookeen est enfin arrivé à l'etna
liasse de l'otite ça son voyage sur les
silencieuses routes du nord a duré en
jour je suis venu ici rapides en ski
pourquoi je ne sais pas je suis
probablement juste à la recherche de moi
même en marchant je cherche des réponses
au fond de moi je peux me découvrir ce
que c'est le nord la liberté le calme il
me reste onze jours de marche environ
220km dire eh bien c'est parti prochain
arrêt lenina volokh puis berthod minsk
bien hoxha et ensuite direction
severodvinsk mais il n'est plus seul un
chien errant s'est joint artyom dans
l'un des villages se cherche et d'un
long chemin
le contrôleur aérien et poète illico
nikov se prépare à l'arrivée d'un avion
d'arkhangelsk pour la deuxième fois
cette semaine du jeu des neiges les
panneaux chaque signe doit être
clairement visible depuis le sol et
depuis le ciel sous cet angle
[Musique]
même si la chasse aux phoques dans la
mer blanche est une pratique révolue
depuis longtemps des avions continuent
d'arriver
mais que font ces gens ici au bout du
monde c'est peut-être de cela qu'il
parlera dans son prochain poème c'est le
bout du monde effectivement nous sommes
à l'extrémité nord ouest de la région
d'arkhangelsk les choses les plus
lointaines sont toujours proches de
quelque chose les îles solovki ne sont
pas loin d'ici
ainsi que la cote de terre ce qui comme
disait cette chanson soviétique au pays
des soviets
il y a plus de périphérie vivons et
construisons au milieu de la terre
le voyage dan a aidé sergei avec naias
l'audit ça n'a pas été vain au cours de
leur dernier vol vers la banquise
alors que tout espoir semblait avoir
disparu ils sont tombés sur des grandes
colonies de phoques du groenland
enfin on a attendu sa dix jours
de grands groupes de 30 à 50 individus
sont dispersés sur une étendue de huit
kilomètres à quelques centaines de
mètres les uns des autres
il n'y avait pas moins de 5000 phoque
selon mon évaluation approximative et
super plaisir
[Musique]
et bien tout d'abord je suis heureuse
que nous ayons découvert quelques sites
où se trouvent les phoques
on a vu quelques milliers c'est
formidable
malheureusement à part ce qu'on a vu il
n'ya rien d'autre a mentionné parce que
nous ne faisons pas d'évaluation
scientifique ou de survol des eaux
et ce n'est qu'une toute petite localité
et j'espère que c'est juste un bout de
leur zone d'habitation et qu'il y en a
beaucoup d'autres là bas mais je veux y
croire
[Musique]